about half of the hospital is turned
over to coronavirus patients and the
virus is only just getting going every
person who comes on here needs some
protective equipment but Croydon
University Hospital is one of the worst
affected in London every bed on this
ward has someone suffering from kovat 19
and these are the less seriously ill yet
they still require 24-hour care 7 days a
week the strain on staff has meant
drawing on help from unexpected quarters
really what are you but tough times mean
tough decisions instead of just sitting
at home I decided to come out and be one
of the ones to come in half because I
know this hospital critically needed
extra support and I wanted to be one of
the ones that could help with that it's
meant massive changes with teams working
in tandem to maintain the barrier
leading into the hot zone if I don't
love what someday I wouldn't be here
today I wouldn't be here today every day
my company especially my husband is like
oh just be safe you can tell me not to
come to it because he knows this is what
I signed up for but obviously we've just
get on with it and just do our best but
this disease is unknown and ravaging and
nearly a quarter of kovat patients
who've come into this hospital haven't
survived that's taken its toll
patients are understandably frightened
staff are frightened as well
staff are frightened that they that they
can't automatically make patients better
they can't make this better and they're
frightened for themselves and their own
families and loved ones and their
colleagues some of the recovering
patients want to talk to us so we're
told to get up just for extra protection
inside the hall would so that we don't
cross contaminate we're taken to Pamela
Mills first who's been in the hospital
for two weeks already and who tells us
she's still not right talk us a little
bit about what you've been through
seen to those foods with a fake a really
horrible day
do you think
I'm still going to bed and stay there
and then you get a few days where you're
a bit more like it then the dark you
just can't tell what's today like yeah
yeah is this a good thing or a bad day
for you from today very good this
disease is a vicious one and no one's
considered safe until they're out of
here in the bed opposite Pamela is Beryl
nurse a social worker who think she
caught it by going to two funerals
the funerals shouldn't have been there I
know them years but life and tributes
and death are both not normal now not
for the patients and not for the staff
who are coping with this pandemic Alex
Crawford Sky News at Croydon University
Hospital